[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the press
conference following the European
Council Summit uh we will start with a
statement by the president of the
European Council
CH good afternoon everyone we've just
Clos the European Council the first
point that I wanted to stress is the
support to express for Ukraine Ukraine
is a priority for us and it will remain
a priority we are determined to continue
to offer financial support and that is
in line with the debate we had yesterday
on the midterm review of the mff and we
want to work with the EU also
bilaterally in terms of Military Support
we also addressed uh the question of
frozen assets there was an extremely
good debate on that and there was a
broad desire for us to make decisive
steps forward on this subject and we
presented to the high representative and
the commission the need to come forward
with operational proposals so that we
have the capabilities so that we can
mobilize some of those assets so that we
have Revenue in order to provide
shortterm term support to Ukraine and
then longer term for the Reconstruction
of Ukraine we also addressed the
question of security internal security
at EU level and the importance of
working more closely in the police and
judicial fields to have better exchanges
of information more systematic exchanges
of information intelligence to fight
terrorism we also had the opportunity
after a message that was communicated in
particular by The Finnish prime minister
we also stressed the importance of
acting for the security of critical
infrastructure in terms of migration it
was a pretty brief exchange for this
European Council it is a point that
comes back regularly on the agenda we'll
continue to do so but one point I wanted
to highlight as we had at the Granada
meeting there is broader consensus now
around the table to reinforce
cooperation with third countries
including
through agreements uh that are as
comprehensive as possible that cover the
many different uh facets of cooperation
on this subject but on other subjects as
well and then finally today we had the
opportunity to address several subjects
relating to the external relations of
the European Union our foreign policy we
addressed the Western Balkans in
particular the normalization of
relations between Serbia and Kosovo we
reasserted our determination to to
support that normalization yesterday
there were two important meetings that
took place as you know and what we took
from those meetings is that there was a
clear commitment expressed by both
leaders to implement the agreements that
are on the table and we will continue to
insist that we want those agreements to
be implemented because that is the road
to normalization we also had an exchange
on the situation in the southern
caucuses and again there we are very
determined to continue to act uh we
continue to mediate uh in order to favor
eyes in order to see a return to
normalization between Armenia and aeran
based on the principle of mutual
recognition of territorial integrity and
sovereignty we had a strategic exchange
on that disc subject and it's very
important that we are coordinated there
was clear Unity expressed by the
European Council on that and you will
also see in the conclusions that we
address the question of the Sahel at
this European Council and then finally
turning to the first uh points that we
addressed this morning economy and
competitiveness and also the Euro Summit
obviously I'd like to thank Christine
lagard who was with us who participated
in our strategic discussions on the
economy and there are four four points
that I would like to highlight in
particular the first is that we are all
fully determined to work to strengthen
our competitiveness not just in the
short term but in the longer term of the
European Union and we clearly identified
what the key subjects are the key
priorities in order to improve our
competitiveness and make Headway on such
an important subject this might include
areas where we've got shortages on the
labor market for instance we have have
to take action there there's also the
question of regularization making sure
that we have regulations in place to
make sure that there are no breaks to
Economic Development and that we have
assets for our economy and competi to
strengthen our foundations and then of
course competitiveness is linked to the
whole question of energy significant
progress has been made since the start
of the war in Ukraine but as several
colleagues
even today we are still seeing Energy
prices that are four times higher than
what we had before that is having a
significant impact in particular on
smmes and households uh jobs that's
another important point and the fourth
one I wanted to mention is the
importance of Investments we need to
invest we have to invest more and more
quickly when we look at the big Reg
regions of the world we see that there
are regions where there are massive
Swift Investments and we have to be very
very active in this respect as well ties
in with other policies to such as the
mobilization of means within the EU but
also national resources means to
stimulate private investment and to
encourage uh our businesses to gain in
confidence uh work on the social economy
that's being led by the European Union
and so on and then the final point is I
would like to congratulate Greece
further to the progress that's been made
this is very visible through the ratings
agencies and I think we've clearly
demonstrated that the Euro zone is an
area of prosperity of solidarity on the
economic front and therefore we're very
pleased uh with the situation now in
Greece and quite a few of us have
congratulated Greece today for this
result I congratulate the authorities on
that success so those are the few points
I wanted to share with you further to
that Summit the president of the
European commission Ula veline you have
the floor yes thank you very much we had
a very dense discussion this morning
with a multitude of uh subjects so I
will choose a few and report on those
indeed we started the day with a very
very good discussion about Europe's
economic
competitiveness and here I would report
on four different strands first that it
is so important to continue to build on
our strength and we have many strengths
in other words we have to focus on the
areas where we already have a
Competitive Edge or where we could take
the lead and for this our industrial and
our energy policies um are putting us on
the right path you're familiar with uh
the the elements for example The Net
Zero industry Act Or the critical raw
materials act but also now the reform of
the electricity Market is important to
drive the production of Renewables up
and thus the energy prices down um and I
very much welcome the agreement that we
have found this week in Council so now
we can proceed with that reform and
there is the platform that we called
step for strategic Investments part of
our proposed revised EU budget um step
is the fund that we want to create to
step up investments in emerging and
strategic Technologies and I hope that
all these proposals will be adopted soon
so that we can kind of start our
economic future right now my second
point is uh different it's as of course
as Technologies are important as
important are the people to work with
these Technologies and this is something
we have also discussed on Wednesday
afternoon with the tripartite summit um
what we need to do is um because it's
developing more and more into a do
bottleneck of for our economy is to look
at the labor market and the lack of
skilled labor or even labor so the
shortages have to be addressed and we
discussed that we have to tap into the
existing potential and improve the
situation we have have a record low um
unemployment rate of 6% but if you look
in the different uh elements um of the
labor market we see that we have a much
higher youth unemployment so first task
to address then we see that the female
participation is way lower than 12%
points lower than the male participation
in the workforce so here we have to
engage in the important topic of
creating the infrastructure to reconcile
work and family like kindergarten and
good schools but also of course have
reconciliation of work and family in the
companies the third element where
there's a lot of untapped potential are
the older workers and the fourth we
discussed is legal migration we had last
year 3.7 million legal migrants coming
to our labor market and this is very
good and we need more of this the
discussion we have in migration is on
the 300 400,000 irregular migrants and I
will report later on this one but the
legal migration is important for our
country and we will need more of this
finally my third point for the topic of
competitiveness um of course we have to
do our homework in the European Union
itself but we also have to make sure
that we have a Level Playing Field
globally for our
companies um and we have in this context
discussed the inflation reduction act
again
um the immediate macroeconomic impact at
the moment being is minor but if you
look at the sectorial implications they
are measurable so we need to stay very
Vigilant especially when we come now
into the phase where we do have for the
European green deal the whole
legislative framework in place but now
it goes into
implementation and the path to
implementation is via guidelines we have
to shape the guidelines now and to make
sure that the clean Tech
Industries um have a competitive
advantage in the European Union it is
important that we listen now to them
what is for them crucial when we
Implement uh the legislation these are
the so-called clean um clean tech
dialogues that we have uh with our
industry so we go sector by sector by
sector to identify where we can support
um our
industry this big work and more about it
should not distract us from the much
greater impact of unfair practices that
we see by China also a part of the
discussion and I want to conclude with
the fact that yes we need a strong
economic base to build our future
competitiveness it's a challenge but
what we also need are fiscal rules that
can match that challenge because sound
public finances open the space for more
investment and we should press ahead
with the adoption now of our proposed
new rules for the European uh economic
governance here I welcome that the
Spanish presidency is working
intensively and tirelessly on uh this
matter indeed at the end of this
discussion we took the opportunity to
congratulate Greece for the
extraordinary Pro progress it has made
over the past year years regaining
investment grade is a significant
Milestone and we pay tribute to the
Greek people who have made enormous
sacrifices but have every reason to feel
good they have been incredibly resilient
still a lot remains to be done but I'm
confident that Greece will continue on
the path of sustainable and inclusive
growth now let me turn to
Ukraine it was very clear in the debate
despite the geopolitical tensions in the
Middle East our Focus continues to be on
supporting
Ukraine and this is why I very much
welcome that uh you invited yesterday
president zalinski to speak to us um uh
via VTC we will continue delivering the
much needed weapons and ammunition we
will continue providing the much needed
Financial relief just to a figure um Al
together if if you look at Team Europe
we have provided almost 83 billion EUR
of assistance to Ukraine now looking
forward the next step is the adoption of
the 50 billion Euro Ukraine facility
because Ukraine needs reliable and
predictable financial
support of course we will continue also
to support Ukraine at as it walks the
path leading to accession we will
provide our assessment as you know on
such progress um at the beginning of of
November a final word on sanctions we
are in the process of preparing the 12th
package of sanctions now we are in the
consultations with the member states in
particular we are looking into how to
cut the remaining revenues Russia draws
from the export of diamonds to Europe
and its Partners this would be done in
very close cooperation with our G7
partners and we continue to make sure
that our existing sanctions are properly
implemented and effectively
enforced a last point on the immobilized
assets of Russia in the European Union
this was also a PO point of discussion
we all recall that it was in March last
year that we took collectively the
important political decision to
immobilize Russian Sovereign assets the
value of these asset stands at 21
billion
Euro and politically we agreed that
ultimately Russia must pay for the
long-term reconstruction of
Ukraine we had a recent discussion of
Finance ministers in marash that allowed
good progress on the basic principles so
the next step would be then an actual
proposal we're currently working on a
proposal to initially focus on the
so-called wind fall pro profits in other
words we will present a proposal to find
a way how to use the proceeds from those
assets that are currently benefiting a
limited number of financial institutions
in the European Union these windall
profits are already quite substantial
and the idea is to pull them and then to
channel them through the EU Budget on
block to Ukraine and the reconstruction
of
Ukraine on
migration there was a strong support for
the letter I sent to the leaders and I
will not reflect on the details of the
letters but the main messages the main
message is that we're making good
progress on the two track approach you
know on the one hand it's the
legislative track here the discussions
on the different pieces of legislation
under the migration and Asylum pact are
advancing well I I would like to thank
uh the council and the Parliament for
this and for all their efforts and now
we must keep up the momentum because we
have to adopt this pact the other track
is the operational work we are making
good progress on the implementation of
the 15 priority actions that we
discussed in January we have taken um
action to address the immediate
situation along the different migratory
routes that we have and we have worked
on advancing our cooperation with
partner countries and this is the
principle also in moving forward now so
we will focus first of all on preventing
irregular departures for this we have to
increase the capacity of the neighboring
countries for Border surveillance and
search and
rescue then we need more Outreach to
countries of origin and transit for this
purpose we need to build much more
comprehensive and mutual beneficial
partnership agreements as we have
discussed for example uh yesterday with
Egypt then there is the important topic
that we have to crack down the on the
Smugglers and
traffickers um in this context um we
will present legislative proposals to
fight Smugglers and traffickers by the
end of November the legislation that we
have in place is 20 years old so it's
high time to up updated and we will
reinforce our cooperation with the UN
agency mostly un
ODC on top we will soon host an
International
Conference to launch a Global Alliance
with a call to action against Smugglers
who to whomever you speak whether it's
country of origin or country of transit
or a country where uh the debate of
migration is intense all understand and
want to C bre down on the cynical
business of Smugglers and traffickers
this is organized crime and we have to
fight it like we fight organized crime
finally on returns as you know the
return rate this year so far has been
22% of those who have a return decision
this amount has to increase therefore we
offer to member states much more closer
cooperation as team Europe to speed up
the procedures to ensure the mutual
recognition of return decisions you have
the decision in one member states it's
valid for all 27 member states and most
importantly to organize joint return
operations now the better we are in the
part that I mentioned at the very
beginning the legal migration the legal
Pathways the investment in education the
more we can be strict in the part of
irregular migration and this was finally
the conclusion also of the debate on
migration and I will stop here thank you
thank you president well we'll open the
floor to questions so we start with the
lady in white
yeah uh thank you very much Le PR
Bloomberg News I have a question for
Madame President um the commission
requested additional funds uh from
member states
but is there also understanding where
the cuts will come from has the
commission maybe a clear list a clear
understanding and if so why wasn't it
shared by member states ahead of this
meeting thank you very much yeah the
process is as follows um there is the
initial proposal of the commission that
this has been done months ago um then
the proposal goes into let's say the
working structures and here the Spanish
presidency has done a great great job in
producing now three different nego boxes
negotiation
boxes um these negotiation
boxes
comprise the different views of the
different 27 member states so you see a
maturing process in these negotiation
boxes um it was and is important that in
between there is a t theable to have the
leaders views in general the political
views so yesterday the debate was not on
fact figures but it was on the general
political view and here you see of
course that there are different views on
uh not on the priorities they were
broadly accepted so that it is important
to support Ukraine that we need to um do
more on migration that uh natural
disasters um and humanitarian Aid has to
be funded and that we have to work on
our competitiveness that a step so the
priorities are broadly accepted there
are certainly the one or the other still
added by member states like defense but
the question is now where do you get the
resources and here it's either National
contributions or it is so-called
redeployment from the EU budget of
course um you can you you will of course
guess that there are different opinions
on um how to mobilize the necessary
funding there was some discussion also
on new own
resources these are important but till
they are in place it will take a certain
while two or three years depends on when
the legislation is uh ready we have
already uh proposals on the table for
new own resources like from the emission
trading system or the carbon border
adjustment
mechanism um so for the mid and long
term these are good and necessary but
for the short term we have the two
instruments n um National contributions
or
redeployment thank you president we'll
start yeah they in the room on the right
side thank you very much AA hajus from
Al jaaz balcans I have a question for
the president of the council I'm just
wondering how optimistic you are after
yesterday's meetings with uh vuic and
kurti uh uh and uh bearing in mind that
both leaders basically did not agree uh
on the European proposals about the
association of Serb municipalities and
what are the details of these proposals
proposal because we haven't heard any
details from the bo leaders from the
Balkans thank you well thank you I would
like to repeat that we had two very
important meetings because we were
together on the EU side with Y Borel
Chancellor Schulz Emanuel Macon and P
Mone and we we passed a message to both
leaders in the in the region and we
explained what we expect from them and
what what we expect from them is to
implement uh the agreements the various
agreements and indeed what you have
mentioned uh this topic of the Serbian
municipalities the association of serban
municipalities is one of the important
elements not the only one but this is
one of the important elements that must
be implemented in our opinion point one
point two this is true and I'm certain
you are perfectly informed that there is
a debate on the sign nature of those
agreements because of the fact that
Serbia does not recognize Kosovo at the
time being based on the constitution of
Serbia or at least the interpretation of
the Constitution of Serbia by by the
Serbian authorities but the most
important element and this was a point
made by various leaders today in the
European council meeting the most
important element is the fact that both
leaders in present of the European
Representatives they made very clear
that they intend to implement those
agreements and I think that the days to
come the weeks to come uh will be
extremely important to check uh if
indeed those Agreements are implemented
and it would be the responsibility on
the EU side to assess what are the
consequences what are the consequences
if this implemented and what are the
consequences if it is not
implemented thank you we go with the
span with the F FN no
hello not euron
news hello euron news I have a question
for both of you but maybe particularly
for you Madame President because you
speak um regularly about having
agreements with third countries in order
to control migration the agreement that
you have right now with Tunisia is in a
relatively bad shape because earlier
this month Tunisia sent you back 60
million that you had uh dispersed in
budget support uh pres K sayette called
the money and I quote charity uh what do
you think about this Tunisian refund how
do you feel about it can you still trust
this country as a strategic partner as
you once call it and then looking
forward how confident are you that that
you can sign more memorandum of
understanding with countries that are
probably going to be ruled by an
authoritarian regime thank you the
comprehensive partnership we are
striving for and we are agreeing with uh
different countries third countries is
specifically uh wider in the concept so
it's not only focusing on uh migration
but it is focusing on
investment for example in infrastructure
for renewable energy because typically
these countries have vast natural
resources like wind and sun and space
but are lacking the infrastructure to
produce renewable energy not only for
EXP Port but also for their own people
um it includes investments in education
with the purpose also be it either
schools or dual vocational training or
connecting universities with our
universities the mediteranian
universities for example with the
expectations that we establish a system
what I just also mentioned where we put
much more emphasis on the regular legal
migration
Talent
Partnerships um so this benefits the
country itself and of course it benefits
also Us in this
partnership um what we also uh discuss
are partially and it's not in every uh
country the same mixture financial
support I very much put very much
emphasis on the investment part I think
this is the most crucial one because
it's the most sustainable in this
context uh we also agree to address the
um organized crime around smuggling and
trafficking and there too um it is
important that we join forces to fight
this organized crime um we've seen that
from Tunisia after uh the time where um
we saw the the uh High numbers of
arrival to lampedusa the figures have
gone down so we see first positive
effects more importantly are more
important are the investments in as I
said the infrastructure or the
educational system we're working on a
similar blueprint with
Egypt um Egypt is very open to establish
such a comprehensive partnership um but
there are also other examples for
example our Co cooperation with
Bangladesh which is bearing fruit
already uh in the sense that their
systematic Return of the those who come
irregularly but we have established a
talent partnership and legal migration
in a transparent and open
way thank you president Lisa and then
we'll take another question and we'll
wrap it up
y um do I have to press
anything it's it's working yeah yeah it
do um just a very quick question for
Adam president um could you tell us what
kind of conversation you had with Victor
Orban thank you
me I did not have a bilateral today with
Victor so he was in the council but uh
there were all the 27 leaders and uh yes
among them me too but not a special
conversation with Victor Orban or are
you referring to a specific event I'm
just wondering what was
Mee what was said about his meeting with
um
Putin ah so uh there were so let's say
the the approach of the leaders was um
in general a leader is Sovereign and
free to choose uh his or her discussion
Partners but what we need is close
coordination and what we need is
transparency if the content of the
discussion affects the European Union
and the unity in the European Union that
was the General message that was
sent thank you and the last question
we'll take
yeah
froms I have a question on the war in
Gaza unfortunately I um um was in at the
press conference yesterday evening but
the massacre is ongoing today now since
Saturday in the war Summit the countries
who are often identified as European
Partners namely Egypt Jordan Saudi
Arabia the Palestinian
Authority are constant L um claiming in
the UN and in other con other talks that
are taking place I'm sure as well
they're calling for a ceasefire but
unfortunately the press release doesn't
allude to that it doesn't indicate any
prospects and it's very difficult not
for me not to say even indirectly that
the European Union is is backing or
covering the massacre which is currently
ongoing now why isn't it lending an ear
to its Arab Partners who know better
know Gaza better than anyone else thank
you we gave a United position a very
clear position a very firm position it's
important not to misinterpret it that
very clear position that is that was
adopted
yesterday and it was adopted quickly as
well within the space of a few hours of
discussion based on a text which had
been prepared and which was virtually
accepted as it stood um with the
addition of a point regarding an
International Peace conference now what
is the main message the message is that
we call for the implementation of
humanitarian corridors and humanitarian
pauses so that that's very clear we
consider it to be extremely urgent
important and indeed essential to ensure
that humanitarian Aid is able to reach
those to whom it is addressed and we're
very exercised on this topic so apart
from the press release there are some
very uh operational ideas put forward by
a number of member states aimed at
genuinely and effectively conveying
humanitarian Aid to those to whom it is
addressed and these points regarding uh
humanitarian corridors and pauses are
clearly intended to ensure that the aid
is effective and there's another point
that we're very exercised when it comes
to the hostage issue as well and we've
we're in close touch with the leaders in
the region who are trying to mediate and
this is vital that we constantly try to
keep on pushing for the hostages to be
released uh without delay and there's
another Point as well here again we are
extremely resolved to work in close
cooperation with the member states and
leaders in the region in order to enable
foreign citizens some of whom are
Europeans to to get out and we're aware
that there are many other citizens who
are unable to get out they are blocked
at the moment and we're keen to get them
out as quickly as possible and the the
humanitarian Dimension is extremely
important and as I said yesterday and I
said it again today in the European
Council we are very very mobilized in
this area and we are very keen to do our
absolute utmost to relaunch the
political process the peace and security
process in order to ensure that very
soon an International Conference can be
held on this topic which was highlighted
by uh prime minister Sanchez yesterday
throughout our discussions and it was
then decided by the heads of state and
government to endorse to share that
ambition which has a lot of support on
the political and diplomatic front and
you're right in saying that we are
indeed very determined to take action in
a coordinated and United manner together
with all our partners in the region very
much